[Music]
[Music]
don't ever let somebody tell you you
can't do something the first step before
anybody else in the world believes it is
you have to believe it you want to take
the easy way out because you're scared
and you're scared because if you try and
fail there's only you to blame let me
break this down for you life is scary
that used to it there are no magical
fixes
get up off your keister get out of here
and go start doing the work
nothing in this world that's worth
having comes easy
[Music]
everybody has a hard road I wanted to
jump out of windows several times during
my young life we all go through hard
times we all go through depression we
all do go through doubt and then moments
in your life where it's really difficult
and you're trying to figure out what
your path is going to be but that is
what makes you a person and those
difficult moments are what build your
character
[Music]
greatness is not this wonderful esoteric
illusive godlike feature that only the
special among us will ever taste you
know it's something that truly exists in
all of us it's very simple this is what
I believe and I'm willing to die for
here
[Music]
today I consider myself the luckiest man
on the face of the earth
with
[Applause]
the universe is a plain canvas you are
the painters the universe the future is
a blank page you are the writer's
[Music]
my soul is not contained within the
limits of my body my body is contained
within the limitlessness of my soul